eight years ago i met my now wife and i
was dating her and for nine months i
didn't tell her i loved her and all her
friends were like oh he doesn't like you
he doesn't like you but i wanted to make
it a huge moment and that's my family
right there
so on new year's eve in hawaii fireworks
going off was the first time i told her
i loved her because i wanted to make it
memorable and now we're married uh going
on six years and we have two beautiful
kids and to my wife claire that's
watching and oliver and elise i love you
guys so much you are my life oh and
she's right there my wife is right there
she's very clear
i love her too we love i love her just
as much as you do i know you do i know
you except when i told her i loved her
she said thank you yeah you can stay
back no
and you know what's funny when i finally
told my wife i loved her she didn't say
oh i love you too she says it's about
time
that's a woman you gotta keep that's
right that's how you know she's a keeper